because for for me obviously growing up
like when I thought of Detroit I thought
like obviously Eminem but then uh there
was guys like Royce the five nine uh
guilty Simpson Black Milk J dilla a lot
of like slum Village a lot of them yeah
um
now like I feel like
because that was kind of more boom bap
like real like rap you know traditional
hip-hop [ __ ] and now it's like the
street shooting Detroit is just kind of
running the running [ __ ] like he's
saying the picture for you for sure who
would you say was like the first artist
of this new era to kind of bring the
national attention to the city in terms
of like maybe the last five or six years
uh you gotta say tea yeah Grizzly for
sure right yeah
it should have been going crazy since
for real yeah that first day out I feel
like kicked the whole door down right it
was hard for the whole city for
everybody for sure shout out to Flint
too Flint's going crazy come on Fremont
Nigeria really uh we uh definitely uh
got love for Rio Flint's great
I feel like the sound's not not the same
but it's kind of like y'all you know
y'all cousins for real you guys are more
like brothers you guys are siblings
are they from the city do you feel me
Flint the same thing yeah no more people
100 percent